ortel falle ich wollte mich cool up
langer zeit schon mal ein kleiner verlag
seines hochgeladen und da die bei euch
relativ gut ankam
[Musik]
richtig hammer das war schon heute an
werden ist dafür die note in die
playlist namens importen videos sind
über 100 über 200 verschiedene videos
drin die alle relativ kurzen die aber
auch teilweise witzig komisch verstörend
sind ich wollte dafür eigentlich
zusammen mein kumpel markt machen
allerdings melde ich mich
[Musik]
mutter vor gap bei google bilder einfach
nicht weil er wirklich fördern einfach
eine übernahme klausur der fit for work
for one die feld ich mach das ganze mal
jetzt auf promotion befreit sie läuft da
vorne wie labert nur über irgendwas
verkauft vielleicht irgendwas und jetzt
realisiert die auf alle ich freue mich
cool aber es klappt mit
es ist jetzt da und sieht vor das maul
[Musik]
ich lache immer nur wenn irgendwer auf
die fresse fliegt wartet hier schaut
euch das an dieser typ erst um die ecke
und jetzt macht er werbung für sein
produkt läuft nach unten und jetzt
gehört er die kameraden und jetzt will
er wieder nach oben laufen merkt dabei
erste stufe
[Musik]
ich war da sind ich war tatsächlich war
das medium die web gerade ihre barbie in
dieses gerede gerät gibt ihr barbie
irgendwie so viel energie wie viel an
schwung dass ihr fliegt und die badi
bewegt wie das feuer
ich will nicht wissen das papier bin ich
sag jetzt mal ein halber geschwindigkeit
abspiele also gefordert mal ein halber
geschwindigkeit an
dieses video wurde entfernt weil es im
youtube-video zum verbot von abrede
verstößt youtube also ich mag ich aber
ich hab auch ich habe vor ein paar tagen
von video hochgeladen wo ich bei so
einer website auf ein paar wochen
reagiert habe und ich habe alles
zensiert die so lange daran das ganze
video durchzugehen alle dinge zu
erfinden 18
youtube hit du bekommst den preis für
den dümmsten voll spaß in dieser folge
[Musik]
das ist eine starke leitung reichstag
hatte durch ein fenster gesprungen
[Musik]
der typ der die gebühren dann hat sie ja
schon angefangen befinden wo sie einfach
nur standen leise angefangen filme die
einfach losgelaufen und voll durch das
fenster
warum also in meinen katzen sind damit
komplett die sind schon da mache ich
doch nicht komplett dumm
[Musik]
video nochmal ein vierfach atomenergie
seinen bmw will cool sein vor seinen
freunden springt runter auf dem bmx mit
den tüten drauf das ist doch alles gut
und dann wurde die nun die fakten
[Musik]
ich muss ich lachen müssen einfach nur
verstören gerade
[Musik]
doch was
das für typen
denn ich dachte wirklich als ich mir das
video hier gerade angebot habe dass er
irgendwann weihnachtsmarktes oder so
aber ich meine schauen uns doch mal an
ihn wir sehen hier unten diesen kleinen
hund und mega blüht und dann vor allem
die mädels einfach so ihr hund hat
gerade geknabbert doch gerade wieder auf
wie guckt rotkäppchen schritt beiseite
guckt für holger das wirklich meinen
hohen guckt so dahin und jetzt nimmt sie
einfach gleich ihre handwerklich oder
der hohen
[Musik]
slater
was ist los mit euch verfügte
[Musik]
fakt war dass das gleiche video ich
schwöre euch der typ kann ein paar neue
hauptplatz einem von der schildkröte
[Musik]
wir wissen doch alle und jetzt wurden
alle die auf seinen kopf und er findet
jetzt im ballon an und mehr und mehr
brennt
besser geburtstag
[Applaus]
er will einen coolen kickflip machen
b
[Musik]
weder
ich glaube das hat wehgetan das war
meine damen ich hätte mir ehrlich gesagt
wird die nutzer vorgestellt aber ich
wollte mir die pleite zeit nicht vorher
anschauen
um es mit euch zusammen decken das video
könnt ihr euch vielleicht hatten wir uns
erhalten wenn ihr jetzt noch dran sind
und euch das video wirklich wird männer
gegeben hat dann schreib mal lachen
in die kommentare
meiringen hier findet ihr und weil ich
ein geländegängiger drauf hier könnt ihr
einen kanal abonnieren sie findet hier
irgendein weiteres video eingeblendet 6
aus
damit auch mein job